I represents the square root of negative
one right so for example if you're
taking the square root of negative 16
you can split this up into square root
of negative 1 times square root of 16
the square root of 16 is 4 and the
square root of negative 1 is I so we
just write this as 4 I so again that I
is just representing the square root of
negative 1 now if you look at I squared
okay I square it is I times I right and
we have the square root of negative 1
times the square root of negative 1 and
this just equals negative 1
ok and then if we look at I cubed I
cubed is I squared times I to the first
right because when you multiply you add
the exponents I squared is negative 1
times I which gives us negative I and
then if we look at I to the fourth we
get I squared times I squared again
you're multiplying so you add the
exponents negative 1 times negative 1
which equals positive 1 so essentially
what happens here is that we have I to
the first which is I I to the second
which is negative 1 I to the third which
is negative I and I to the fourth which
is 1 and then it repeats so I to the
fifth would go back to I I to the sixth
I to the seventh I to the 8th and it
just keeps repeating like that so if you
can remember this pattern that's one way
to approach these problems okay the
other way to do it is to look at I
squared okay in particular and I'll show
you in these examples of two different
ways how to approach this so let's look
at this first example I to the 73rd now
one easy technique that a lot of
students really like is they'll say well
how many times does 2 go into 73 well
you can see it's 36 times with one left
over because power to power you multiply
that's 72 and when you multiply and have
the same base you add the exponents so
plus one more that's 73 right but I
squared you can see that's negative 1 to
the 36 power times I now negative 1 to
an even power is positive 1 right so
then times I would give us I so I to the
73rd is just I okay so that's one
technique is trying to see how many
times that you know 2 goes into 73 and
how many are left over and then just
work with I squared which is negative
one like we talked about over here
that's the first technique the second
technique is you can say
let me see how many times 4 goes into 73
remember how we talked about it repeats
every 4 like here's I of the 1st 2nd 3rd
4th and then it repeats so you can say
well let's see how many times 4 goes
into 73 it goes in here let's see hmm
once that's 4 subtract 4 goes into 33
let's see hmm
18 times ok remainder 1 okay now this is
interesting remainder 1 means that it's
going to be I if it's a remainder 2 it's
going to be negative 1 remainder 3
negative I remainder 4 there's no
remainder okay then it would just be 1
okay so if you can remember that I'll
just maybe write that over here so it's
a remainder 1 that means its I remainder
2 that means it's negative 1 remainder 3
that means that it's negative I and if
there's no remainder
no remainder then it's just going to be
1 so it has to be one of these answers
either I negative 1 negative I or 1 okay
and you can see we have remainder 1 so
that's going to be I so you can you know
think about this little way here of
doing it or you can think about I
squared let's do a couple more examples
and you'll get it down so I to the 52nd
let's look at that one down here how
many times does 2 go into 52 26 times
right with nothing left over so I
squared is negative 1 but a negative 1
to an even power a negative times a
negative times a negative even number of
times that's gonna be a positive 1 ok so
that was pretty easy right but if you
want to use this technique of dividing
by 4 okay we're gonna do the same thing
four goes into 5 once right
with 12 left over 13 0 remainder right 0
remainder means what no remainder means
that the answer is 1 so you can get the
same answer so some students prefer you
know this technique and other students
just prefer this technique because it's
a little bit less to remember you just
have to remember you know I squared is
negative 1 let's look at I to the 1 Oh
third power here so I to the 103 hmm I
had a 103 that's I squared to the 51st
power right because that gives you 102
power to a power you multiply with one
left over well I squared is negative one
we've got a negative 1 to an odd power
which is negative 1 times I we get
negative I okay now if you want to do it
the other way you just take 103 divided
by four that's 2:23 let's see that's
five that's twenty looks like we're
getting remainder three what happens
when we get remainder 3 we're getting
negative I see the same thing that we
have here so you can kind of pick which
one that you like the best let's just do
one final example so just kind of
solidify everything we've talked about
here let's see I to the 48th power so
see if you can figure this one out on
your own maybe you can pause the video
if you want
so I squared is let's see to the 24th
power because power to power you
multiply right I squared is negative 1 a
negative 1 to an even power is positive
1 and so it should just be positive 1
now if you want to use the technique of
dividing by 4 you can see this goes in
12 times with 0 remainder when we get 0
remainder the answer is 1 just like we
got there so again I hope this helps you
understand how to work with higher
powers of I subscribe to the channel
check out more videos on Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel that's me and
I look forward to seeing in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon